with Rising fees and stagnating graduate
wages these days University can feel
like a risky investment
here's the economist tips on how to make
your degree worthwhile
[Music]
in England graduates in economics
medicine and Computing almost all get
positive Returns on their studies making
back the money they invested
other grads aren't as lucky
negative returns are likeliest for those
studying creative arts
this is especially true for men less
than 10 percent of male Creative Arts
students ever make back their investment
while traditional wisdom suggests opting
for elite institutions like the ivy
league or Russell group
our research suggests it's what you
study not where that most affects how
much you make
but don't be tempted to try to cheat the
system
researchers in Norway discovered that
students who wanted to study Humanities
but opted for the Sciences instead
actually earned less than they would
have had they stuck with their passion
across the rich World less than 40
percent of undergrads finish their
degree on time
that means even more fees on top of loss
of potential income
in America every additional year you
spend at University costs on average 38
000 in fees and lost earnings
surprising that
think of Americans believe a degree is
no longer worth the time and money
but on average graduates do earn more
than their High School educated peers
for men the Gap in America is nearly six
hundred thousand dollars over a lifetime
of course the benefits you gain from
University depend on many different
factors
but the numbers do suggest ways to get
the best bang for your educational buck
so choose well and finish on time
[Music]
thanks for watching if you'd like to
read more from The Economist please
click the link
and don't forget to subscribe
[Music]